you know this one really grinds my gears
I'm seeing all these people claim that
George Soros endorsed Ron DeSantis and
he quite literally didn't George Soros
said he hopes that the Sanderson Trump
go to war so that the Republican Party
rips itself apart and Democrats went in
a landslide and the Republicans are
forced to reform themselves or something
like that but I think a lot of the
people who really want Trump to win see
Ronda Santos as a threat so they're
running with this fake story quite
literally the Gateway pundit edited a
quote from George Soros to make it seem
like he was endorsing Ron DeSantis when
in fact he didn't so we'll talk about
that because that one pisses me off look
man I don't I don't mind Trump I like
him for a lot of reasons I like his
hands for a lot of reasons I think Trump
is better for some reason I think
DeSantis is better for some other
reasons but the fastest way to lose my
vote is to lie to me the other story we
got is uh fetterman I guess he's out
he's gonna be in the hospital for weeks
he's depressed his brain isn't working
he's getting worse I guess we'll just do
the countdown maybe we'll get a timer
for the show as to when Joe Biden
appoints his wife to be a senator when
he when he bows out so we'll talk about
that plus we got some interesting
stories uh coming out of the New York
Times apparently they are now
complaining they've hired too many
activists but the funny thing about it
is it took him 10 years to figure it out
so we'll talk about that before we get
started head over to timcast.com become
a member to support our work over at
timcast.com and click that join us
Button as a member you'll get access to
exclusive uncensored members only shows
Monday through Thursday they usually go
up at about 11 p.m not so family
friendly and smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends but tonight we
actually do have a members only show so
uh we are being joined by the great and
Coulter so I was very excited and
normally we don't do members only
segments for Fridays but I was like we
we definitely have to record something
special with Ann Coulter because it's
it's an honor honor and a privilege to
have you here so that will go up at uh
at 10 p.m and all we did was I was just
like let's just press record as we're
doing show setup because often there's
some interesting conversation and we'll
capture that and I think people might
appreciate you know getting to see a
little bit of the candid conversation
Ian talking about God I know we're
recording that's awesome yeah that was a
good combo it was and that's why I was
like we should record this yeah and then
we will have a members show so that'll
be up at 10. and obviously joining us
tonight to talk about a whole bunch of
stuff is Ann Coulter hello thank you for
having me I'm so excited to be here yeah
I think everybody knows who you are but
would you want to introduce yourself for
those that maybe live under a rock um
I'm banned every place that's why I
started a sub stack
including the shadow Banning and we were
talking about this earlier I'm I'm not
the huge fan of elongs that I was when
he first bought it because I'm not
really getting the shadow band lifted
and um I mean this I was skiing this
week's so I I do videos every week on my
sub sack and this one was sort of a
fluffy one it was with supermodel Alana
Stewart It's a friend of mine from LA
and I just wanted to talk to her about
her Jet Set lifestyle and you know how
she met George Hamilton and Rod Stewart
and what it was like and back when
models were pretty and she's very very
pretty
um it was the tamest interview I've ever
done and Twitter slaps a sensitive
content label on it for what just coming
after you no idea idea I I clicked on do
you want to appeal and it goes through
paragraph and well this is sensitive
content warning and we don't allow
um sensitive content and we can't have
sensitive content and this has sensitive
content nothing about what was sensitive
about it two good-looking women in a
video that you posted it's dangerous
it's propaganda I don't I one person
told me I don't know if this is true
um because you know I want to want to
make the headline sound exciting and and
also she's she is lovely and has a
lovely figure so I I want to get into
stuff that girls might want to know so
have you ever had to diet what do you
eat how do you look so beautiful so I
put you know Alana Stewart talks
um you know supermodel Life diet how
Bianca Jagger ended up with a copy of
one of my books this is you know this
long headline and one of my friends said
the word diet might have been triggering
for fatties so I'm thinking the word it
wasn't about diets it's what is your
diet right well everyone has a diet but
that's why I'm on sub stack and it's I'm
it's such a relief to be on sub sac
because you know during that two-week
period the one time I felt free on
Twitter was the two-week period when it
looks like Elon Musk was going to buy
Twitter but he hadn't bought it yet and
then you know it took a while and then
it looks like he wasn't gonna buy it but
for two weeks I felt like all of the
woke sensors thought oh crap he's coming
in lift the filters lift the filters and
Bam all my followers went through the
roof for two weeks and then he said he
wasn't gonna buy it
Wall came down again and the wall is
back again I mean there are a million
different ways he himself tweeted I
guess last week I'm skiing one of my
friends sent me this might be what's
getting you
um that they will de-amplify people who
have a lot of people blocking Yep
they're tweet well that's just giving
liberals the hecklers Vita have you
blocked anyone oh I have my first week I
did only because I didn't understand how
Twitter worked literally my first day if
somebody called me the c word I thought
screw you I'm I'm blocking you and then
I realized oh I know just don't follow
this person
if I'm worried that person might show up
in a retweet oh my gosh my eyes will
burn I could mute them easy enough
so yeah to block somebody only a liberal
would do that so obviously if you were
de-amplifying people who are blocked you
are de-amplifying conservatives by
definition that's just one thing they do
and then two weeks ago
I sent out a tweet it wasn't even that
funny a tweet but it was kind of funny
and by I don't know a couple oh I know
what it was two hours later it had a
thousand likes
and then three hours later it had only
200 likes
sorry Twitter did 700 people three hours
after this challenge up think you know
that tweet I liked an hour ago I'm gonna
go find it and unlike it I was wrong I
changed my mind that's why I'm on sub
stack and sub stack is fun I have
comments I interact I do and I post
columns it'll go directly to your to
your inbox but I do videos podcasts and
we have we have a story from you yes you
got the you got a letter from the New
York Times where you're complaining
about wokeness well let's get into all
that stuff uh we'll go through the rest
of the people hanging out I guess I
guess you you know Hannah Claire we're
sorority sisters I'm not even kidding
you're not kidding I'm totally not
kidding we're both Delta Gammas that's
fine I'm Hannah Claire Brimley I'm a
writer for timcast.com we're both Delta
Gammas and uh like all these panhellenic
college sororities will send out emails
saying like look at our notable alums
and this is an actress who's in it and
whatever else and they'll say like
nominate someone and I always used to be
like Ann Coulter when you get a
knowledge that Ann Coulter was it DG and
I used to nominate you for
I noticed that they have never contacted
you to win best Delta gamma of whatever
National hasn't but I maybe it was
because of you the a lot of local Delta
games would send me all kinds of Delta
gamma pair I love getting it I loved
Delta gamos fabulous it was a great time
but a lot of individual colleges Delta
games have sent me stuff I talk about it
I mean I don't talk about it publicly
often but I would tell all of my other
DG friends that Anne was a Delta gamma
and this is great and we should have her
speak at whatever and then I used to
email like whenever Nationals did these
calls because they'd have like an
Instagram post and be like famous people
and I'd be like Anne where's Ann you
have to have Anne there's no point doing
this but yeah uh thank you of course so
uh Ann and I are long time sorority
sisters I'm writer of timcast.com I
think I already said that each follow at
timcast news on Twitter and Instagram hi
everyone Ian Crossland um I'm gonna keep
this moving along a bucko will be making
an appearance I can bring him up sooner
than later we keep thinking about them
so I'm gonna go get bucko while we do
the rounds of intros and he'll be back
soon basically over with you hi everyone
hi sir what's happening Brother yo I'm
pressing buttons pleasure to meet you
Ann Coulter I my parents have been
watching you for a long time they're
happy about this anyways let's get going
let's jump into this first story this
one uh this one pissed me off Newsweek
writes George Soros prays for Rhonda
Santos rattles Trump supporters and
that's putting it lightly I saw Gateway
pundit wrote George the kiss of death
George Soros endorses Rhonda Santos
which he did not do let me show you the
quote because they actually do have the
quote in here quote DeSantis is shrewd
ruthless and ambitious he is likely to
be the Republican candidate this could
induce Trump whose narcissism has turned
into a disease to run as a third party
candidate that would lead to a
democratic Landslide and force the
Republican party to reform itself he
actually said My Hope for 2024 is that
Trump and Governor descendants of
Florida will Slug It Out for the
Republican nomination and then because
it would lead to the Democrats winning
so why I I think I mean I know why I
think people who like Trump are trying
to sabotage Ron DeSantis but
I don't know your thoughts I guess I'm
just I'm kind of pissed off at being
lied to to be honest I'm so glad you
looked up the full quote and can expose
that it is just a complete 100 lie
um coming from Trump supporters yeah
well
and the mainstream media don't get me
wrong you know but at least Newsweek
puts it lightly they're like he prays to
Santa's praised him no he called him
ruthless
I just thought it was stupid they've
convinced me that this is a dog
um and that's why I'm very happy to see
fake news from Anne I just think it's
stupid to decide whether you like a
politician or a person based on who else
likes that person or doesn't like that
person that's what you do when you have
you're looking at a black box you have
no other information who is this Ron
DeSantis you speak of we know about
Rhonda I don't care I I don't care who
endorses him I know the things he's done
he opened up the state Trump shut it
down
um he read the Great Barrington
declaration guys Trump listened to fauci
and allowed him to run covid policy uh
he sent the illegals to to Martha's
Vineyard the greatest political stunt of
my life
I mean it was after all the busing and
everything to take to take the extra
step to go to Martha's Vineyard and man
was that a hit he hired more police
offered police being harassed other
places to come and get a five thousand
dollar bonus to come work in Florida I
mean he's he's just been done hit after
hit after hit so I don't care who
endorses him
they told us he was going to die in a
week and here he is he's looking like
he's getting a little thick he's
starting to eat again he gained um a
quarter pound in the first week after
stem cell treatment he just got another
injection yesterday in some subcutaneous
fluids today so he looks like a little
muscular what does he have it's um
kidney failure they call it it's third
is he a drinker what's that yeah he's
been no he's a street cat he's never
developed correctly yeah he has got
underdeveloped kidneys and a bad heart
so but he started since the stem cell
treatment and the change in his diet
he's extremely a lot better he's like
John Federman yeah stem cells we got him
this experimental stem cell treatment is
he depressed no not anymore he's doing
better he had to shave his little legs
though the fourth one though he's got I
know my legs and one that's still fluffy
so anyway we were talking about uh
Rhonda Santos and Donald Trump uh so
what do you thinking you're voting uh
DeSantis 2024 if he runs right now
though I I'm if if the cameras weren't
running I'd say of course I am he's the
best candidate out there he's the best
in my lifetime
um but since the cameras are running I
want Ron DeSantis to have to fight for
my vote so yes I'm considering him very
strongly we'll see
what uh I mean you've been on you've
been on Twitter quite vocal about Donald
Trump yes yes both ways I mean I did
write in Trump We Trust
but Rally's two weeks after he announced
out in Iowa and elsewhere and look if
you read in Trump We Trust I wouldn't
take back a single word of it in fact
I've given it to certain Republican
presidential candidates I want to read
it saying but you actually have to do it
um because the what the 2016 campaign I
I think was the greatest presidential
campaign in world history but in the
book I make it very clear he's an awful
person he's a con man he's a grifter
um horrible tacky vulgarian got all that
but he's the only one offering us this
basket of issues I want to vote on
obviously number one immigration number
two three and four immigration and the
wall bringing trade back this worship of
free trade
um and no more stupid Wars those were
like the three biggest things and then
any supported things like you know gun
rights very strongly
um and then you know he gets into office
and starts talking about amnestying the
dreamers they're the ones I wanted to
Port first because their boss again
obnoxious at least you know you catch
another illegal alien and they say okay
you got me no dreamers how dare you not
give me amnesty so Trump gets elected
doesn't build the wall builds 33 miles
you know six months before the election
it's a 2000 mile border
um he takes Kim Kardashian noted
criminologist to
to push through laws releasing criminals
that which you know that's a huge hit
with Americans especially after 2020.
that's great yeah well you always know
how to be a celebrity right like that
that reminded me of the reality TV show
aspect of trump right he knew he knew I
don't I think you're giving him more I
don't even think it's knowing how to be
I think he is a narcissistic I I didn't
mean the one thing I didn't know when I
wrote in Trump We Trust is how
profoundly stupid he is
um I made very clear in the book The
only thing he could do we will forgive
him for anything and I defended him the
day after the Access Hollywood you know
grabbing tape came out I was
giving a speech before like 5 000 people
in California up in farmland and I was
peddled to the medal defending him
and and you know I said well forgive
them for anything but unless you betray
us on immigration oh and guess what he
did you can't do every campaign rally
build the wall build the wall build the
wall and then not build the wall and
expect to get reelected well that was
the best part of your Twitter account
for me for a long time was you you're
how many days like no progress on the
wall border wall updates yeah and you I
mean you are intense about it you were
one of the most vocal people keeping his
feet to the fire on the border wall yeah
that works look you fought a good fight
here I mean you can't say that you did
it try I will say to be fair the the
areas that got secure did reduce
illegal immigration in key points you
didn't get a beautiful five million
illegals have come in since Biden's been
president well there's a reason we
wanted a wall a wall is forever and
these people these my my my allies on
the immigration issue who say
um oh the wall that's it's a metaphor we
don't just enforce Evar okay e-verify
goes away with the next president
Refugee limits go away with the next
president a wall is forever Americans
were correct to vote for the guy no
matter how much of a Despicable moronic
grifting human being he was he promised
us a wall and that's why people voted is
DeSantis going to get us a wall
um what I like I think so I think so I
think so I absolutely do and the reason
I say it with that enthusiasm is what I
like about
DeSantis is Trump was all talk no action
DeSantis is no talk
action yeah
what did you think of Doug ducey's um
shipping container wall he like put the
shipping containers in the gaps in the
wall and then he Martin took it down
yeah they were super mad about it
what did you think I mean do you like
that that's why we want a wall and not a
Cheesy little fence that's true I used
to think the wall was such a silly idea
because I was like they'll just go
around it or under it or they'll send
drones over it I didn't realize until
the last couple years how much how much
human trafficking is just happening on a
daily basis that I've got this armband
from yeah this is it says
which means delivered this is put around
the hand the arms of young children that
are sent across the border as cat as as
Commodities basically to be sold the
people that are being trafficked get
marked by this and then we also have
yeah we have that ID a fake ID that they
use to try and get make fake Asylum
claims it's crazy that and we are a
magnet for that sort of human
trafficking it's sick it's sick it's
sick that we're doing this it's sick
that we're doing it to them and it's
just people who hate America and they're
they're willing to risk these human
lives to wreck our contract I think it's
uh completely in line with what
Democrats do short-term gains for
long-term losses one of the big
strategies Democrats have is to
artificially prop up the failing economy
with this economic maximizing as much
demand as possible through illegal
immigration ignoring all the negative
consequences and then 10 years down the
line we're gonna we're gonna face this
very serious economic crisis from it but
they're hoping that they can boost
numbers in the short term to make it
look good
that's true too but long term they win
also they look at California
yeah the entire country will be
California highest taxes in the country
least least numbers of services people
who work for a living are just oppressed
harassed they have to walk through you
know human feces to get to work homeless
camps all over that is your future
America do you think that the allowance
of the this happening across the border
is one of three reasons maybe because
they can't stop it so it's like what are
we gonna do two because they want
uh a huge population that they can turn
into military men I don't know maybe
that's part of it that they want more
fodder for the war machine so they're
letting them in and they're like hey you
can earn your citizens I think they're
not against that but not I think that's
not the number it's more just like
they're overwhelmed and they're like we
don't know how to stop it so we're not
no no that is absolute never believe
that I mean they act that way so sorry I
shouldn't be that dismissive yeah they
all act oh what are you gonna do and oh
people can climb over a wall yeah tell
it to Israel
tell it to China to the capital complex
that put up the wall just the other day
walls always work I mean it's like
saying don't put a lock on your door
isn't that a nice car on a new bed and
focus is laying on stem cells on that I
could use it
um you don't lock your door because you
know a burglar could I don't know take a
hatchet to it or something I mean Israel
had the wall goes deep deep down when
Israel put up its wall
um it cut down uh illegal immigration by
more than 90 percent that wasn't good
enough for Israel so they found after
they had built the wall which parts of
the wall were the most vulnerable and
built those extra high no walls walls
work drones don't work boots on the
ground don't work Thai Tech doesn't work
what are we gonna do watch them run
across that's all an excuse for no wall
open border the only thing that works
was a wall and as for why they wanted it
well long-term Democrats are sitting
pretty in California you came from
California they control every branch of
government
um the illegals who are coming in I I
will say they are very hard workers
they're very nice I bear them no ill
will and they really are hard workers um
but they also consume a lot of
government benefits and they vote
overwhelmingly Democrat and that's what
happened to California Hispanics are now
a plurality it certainly it was
completely the opposite it was like one
of the whitest states in the union
California it was it was the Beach Boys
now there are plurality and Democrats
control the state and that's what will
happen to the entire country in the
immediate they don't need to vote
because what happens is one of the
reasons California at least in my
opinion brings in so many illegal
immigrants is that it inflates their
census numbers which then grants them
more congressional seats and more
electoral votes right so I always tell
people that you know they'll say illegal
immigrants don't vote they don't vote
and I'm like well at the at the federal
level they don't need to if the census
tracks X many people and they get a I
think uh into the 2010s they had one
extra congressional seat and Electoral
College vote one out of 538 votes you're
absolutely right that's that's that's
that's a lot of power to gain from doing
what they're doing I think they're
called ghost districts Maxine Waters
gets elected with like seven votes
because her district is all illegal
aliens but by now in California
everything they've been coming for a
long time they are voting in California
we're just bringing in more and more and
more and why don't the Republicans do
anything about it
um and that's the donors want the cheap
labor yeah I had some of my best friends
in California were illegal aliens from
Mexico or or whatever and they would
work for cash and then they would send
it to Mexico I don't even know if it was
getting taxed no it's not if it's cash
that's just going across the border
there's no way to test it my
compassionate love was there but the
structural system wasn't working it was
very bad for our country that's that's
money that's being sucked out of our
economy and by the way going directly
into the pocket of Carlos Slim who's
that
um the billionaire monopolist of Mexico
he's often competing with Elon as the
richest man in the world and how does he
make it by overcharging these poor
Mexicans so all that money going back is
to pay for his industry it's a very
corrupt country max doesn't doesn't he
own some big Media company or something
but he saved the New York Times that's
right the New York Times is he does he
still a principal owner no but he
stepped in at a crucial moment to save
them they were teetering on on
bankruptcy man I'm talking about like
Bloomberg buying it or somebody else
buying Carlos Slim slept in that for us
was a fortune Forbes Magazine had him is
the richest man in the world from 2010
to 2013.
Carlos so what is he like and he's
selling the a gorgeous Mansion in New
York City for 80 million it was just in
the daily mail yesterday whoa what part
of the city is that in Upper East Side
wow 80 million what the across from the
Met it's magnet it's the red one right
yes it's so pretty it's magnificent what
do we do about the drug cartels that are
running people like drugs across the
border the wall the wall solves so every
problem in America gets easier with a
while every single problem
um race relations poor people bringing
manufacturing back everything gets
easier when you solve immigration
because you don't have this we don't
need an extra problem to deal with and
extra poor people we have to pay for but
the drug problem that's 100 a function
of not having a wall oh one of the
interviews I just did on substack and I
highly recommend you all watch it so
this guy Sam Quinones liberal journalist
but I've been a fan of his for a long
time he was a really good investigator
before you may have read them in the LA
times because his beat was crime and
immigration and he's the only block
quote I have in adios America where it's
like two paragraphs just from his one of
his articles really really good and then
he wrote what your audience may be more
familiar with he wrote the book
Dreamland about the opioid crisis in
America and now most recently
um the least of us about Fentanyl and he
does the reporting he knows the drug he
knew where that all all the um the uh
the meth was coming from it was coming
from like one town in Mexico now it's
changed it's gone out to the cartels but
he knows everything about the drug
problem it is not coming from China it
is meth is being made in Mexico the the
opio it is all coming from Mexico is it
funded by the CCP
Chinese used to send the precursor
chemicals or they would send the heroin
directly or they would send the math
directly but the problem is that's all
in individual like FedEx packages
and they do it but for one thing weirdly
enough the Chinese government actually
did kind of step on them but it was just
inefficient you CA you need to be on the
border you need to get it straight
across and you know they'll say oh but
it's not all Mexicans some of them are
American citizens yeah they're anchor
babies it is an all-mexican operation
interesting I thought I've been thinking
of it as a like just a continuation of
the drug war the Opium Wars the how the
British set up shop in Taiwan and then
just started shuffling yeah opiates into
China and the Chinese never you know
play the long game but you're saying
it's more of just a financial Mexican
issue right now do you feel like since
it's a fight and I think I'm sorry just
to finish that it is Opium Wars but it
is Americans against Americans the same
people who don't want a wall
um there is there is a crazy left I'm
not talking about all Democrats many
liberals are my best friends not talking
about all liberals at all but there is
an element of the left that just hates
this country and they're fine with
Americans dying of opioids they are fine
with a hundred thousand Americans dying
from drugs every year these people also
uh I guess paradoxically don't even know
what life outside of the United States
is they think the United States is evil
and they have no idea they've never been
to the other countries because if you go
to these other countries and you're like
wow America is pretty nice yeah for all
the bad things I remember when I started
traveling for vice after a couple of
these countries I come back to the U.S
and I I got like randomly searched by
the border patrol they made me pull
their pull my passport went through my
bag and I'm just laughing and then they
like they they see the Arabic in my
passport like what's this and then I was
like I don't even remember a country
that was Egypt I think or something
where did I go I can't remember and I
don't know it was uh Morocco and they
were like oh and then they were like
what's funny and I'm like I love this
country man I'm like it's just like
everything's nice here you know I come
back from I was in Brazil or something
and you know you see how you see how
good we have it it's decentralized law
enforcement is what I'm I'm sold under
the United States local cops is the key
to Prosperity having a federal system
where they're like they decide one day
that this is illegal now and everyone in
the country is the key to everything is
the local yeah I totally agree and I
didn't know that until I went to Cuba to
um Chile and and Peru and like saw the
federal cops on the corners I'm like we
have no idea what it's like in other
countries especially because we are so
used to complaining about America right
everyone's saying America's so racist
and America has all these cop problems
and like travel at all go anywhere and
you'll be happy to be here do you think
that Mexico poses enough of a threat to
American lives to be worth invading at
any point
um I it wouldn't be necessary if we
built the wall yeah
um but yes to take out the cartels I
mean it's certainly more of a threat to
us than the Ukraine right and we sent a
ton of money shipping goods and
resources to Ukraine why wouldn't we
just spend that money on the wall on
well not only the wall but as for you
know going into their country
um I mean I don't know this is kind of
racy but yeah take out the cartels if
they can't do it by themselves we went
we got remember that guy pineapple face
the first George Bush sent
um U.S troops he was he was I think I
was like four years old okay the
pineapple pineapple so the solid
nickname here I'll look it up just
just
late 80s it was a big thing but it was
the first it was the first George Bush
sent in our military to to to see yeah
yeah Manuel Noriega I attacked pineapple
face and he showed up on Google search
really Panamanian bets Panama
does it say Bush that isn't I maybe I
wouldn't have done us that that's a
funny uh why are you thinking about him
though because we sent the military to
get him I'm pretty sure that was Noriega
that was your question we've done it
before and wait if I could get back to
your point on local police it's not just
the police look at the covid rules thank
thank God I'm not taking the lord's name
in vain thank God we could go to places
like Florida
what if I mean Trump did shut down the
country you know because he's he's so
for Freedom
um
but New York California versus versus
Texas actually Texas wasn't that good
Georgia was good Florida was good I
don't know whatever places you were
looking at moving to in 2020 you will
remember everything should be local give
us a choice let us vote with our feet
yeah military centralization and
Military Authority law making and dude
the the medical tyranny is I am on alert
for medical tyranny I know the Nazis did
lots of medical science experiments on
living people and I'm not down with that
in real time we're doing it on
adolescent girls right now yeah we are
and they're miserable I mean with
medical tyranny during covid the local
governments were the most likely to
resist right bigger cities and everyone
else were more likely to give in if you
went to any small town in America they
operated differently they operated
independently because they know their
community and they know what they can
handle or the third largest state in the
Union Florida oh hey so what why this um
gun running that Obama did The Fast and
Furious program was he sending arm terms
to the cartels is that what happened
um what happened was
that's wow that's a blast from the past
um no
yes yes he was and the reason they
weren't intentionally hey we have a
program let's send although that was the
suspicion of a lot of Republicans they
wanted crimes being committed with
American Guns
um what they claimed to be doing was
putting tracers on the guns they were
sending and then they could follow where
the guns were going and they could see
where the cartels Hideout is and we
could follow the cartels except the way
it was being done was
so sloppy a lot of the guns didn't have
tracers on them way more than were
necessary they didn't follow where the
guns were going which made some people
think you just want an argument to say
all this cartel violence is being done
with American Guns we need more
restrictions on buying guns in America
I'm concerned about like um actively
giving our weapons to other people so
that we can test our own weapons against
our own weapons like in the Ukraine we
surround not in Ukraine geez we
surrendered in Ukraine guys that's what
I'm about to say uh yeah yeah yeah Biden
surrenders the military in Afghanistan
to the Taliban the greatest military on
Earth he surrendered it to this local
militant group the Taliban for some
reason
um and what is that reason well at first
I just thought it was incompetence now
I'm wondering if Lockheed wants their
arms in the hands of enemies so that
they can test their weapons because they
have no test grounds not just test but
so that there's a reason to sell more
weapons yes oh no the Taliban now has
you know Blackhawks and scud missiles or
whatever so you're gonna have to buy
more from us it's the same argument with
big Pharma making you take drugs that
give you side effects right more drugs
right like if we arm people that we then
are like it turns out they're a threat
when armed anyway so send in the
military and what does your military
need are guns yes it's a it's a perfect
scheme yeah I wanted to ask you uh and
what was your where were you at on the
the Iraq War by back in the day oh I
just I'm so glad you asked I just did a
sub stack with my friend Mickey house
liberal
um and I forget why or how it came up
but I put in a little plug for what my
position was and I would still have that
same position today with you know the
caveat
um it wasn't go hang out for 20 years
and paint George Floyd murals and teach
girls about feminism in these backward
hellholes oh well what else could you do
but no I was I was very much in favor of
both Afghanistan and Iraq and I would be
again today
um
other than not being able to trust I
mean Eisenhower was right with the
military industrial complex and I think
you're right it is about selling weapons
and I think the lobbyists for these arms
companies I mean what's good it is just
endless the wars why were we in
Afghanistan for 20 years and I would
remind you
um well okay maybe you're in first grade
when this happened but
um
there were we we took Afghanistan in two
weeks and after that every year of the
Bush Administration
I'll have Ian check me as his computer
open there there were like 33 American
deaths 50 American deaths 40 American
deaths and for some reason liberals got
in their heads that you know Afghanistan
that's the good war in Iraq we hate that
war so he was so
object pull troops immediately out of
Iraq and send
our troops to Africa understand I did
not understand so you will see when
Obama comes in suddenly it like doubles
and then it triples we were getting like
50 deaths a year until 2005 there's a
hundred hundred and then in 2008 156 300
and 2009 500 in 2010. yeah for
for as long as we went and don't abandon
them as quickly and poorly as we did
because
um and I don't know maybe this was
caring too much about the rest of the
world and I should do what I always
advise Senators like Tom Cotton to do
please come back and care about our
country you're so good when you talk
about our country stop being a neocon
um but uh the funny thing about the
Middle East and we obviously did have a
big problem with the Middle East and
these these crazy
um mullahs after 9 11 is that by and
large the countries either have same
leader insane people or insane leader
sane people and Iraq and Saddam it's not
like we were taking out the Iraqi
Benjamin Franklin there were a lot of
problems there he tried to assassinate a
president
um he had used chemical warfare he had
those lovely Sons Uday and kuse but
mostly he was crazy and that but it was
a very pro-western Highly Educated
populace so yeah I liked Iraq and I made
these arguments at the time I never
cared about weapons of mass destruction
other than to taunt the New York Times
for saying we need you at approval well
okay
he's defined the UN resolution so that I
thought there were a lot of reasons for
going into Iraq but one of them was to
have an Arab Israel to have a democracy
it doesn't have to be like you know
Vermont but something more like a
functioning democracy without a crazy
guy is the leader and by the way I I
think we got that I think a rock is
better today than it was then it would
be a lot better if if Obama hadn't
pulled all the troops out what they what
they wanted for Afghanistan was South
Korea that you stay in the country
occupying it for 50 years and you create
two generations of westernized
population in an attempt to Nation build
and stabilize which I don't think is any
of our business also the internet almost
impossible to do that with the internet
because you can't control the info
information flow anymore everyone knows
what that's true that's what they wanted
though they wanted to create a
generation they wanted to create a
generation that would create a more
westernized I agree with you that nation
building is totally foolhardy yeah I'm
describing something slightly different
with a rock I just want to point that
out Afghanistan
you know they have three working toilets
a rock the compare the literacy rates of
those two countries so if you're
starting with a populist that is already
educated knows how to read and they have
working toilets and don't look at it
like it's a spaceship okay you start
that's something you can work with I
don't want to stick around a nation
build but if you just knock out the
crazy leader they ought to be able to
take it from there take away the barrier
yeah yeah yeah exactly Uday Hussein was
such a psychopath he was like had a the
Iraqi soccer team one of the worst most
despicable people probably ever there's
documentaries about his he would go in
and like whip them and then if they if
they didn't play well enough he would
like beat the hell out of him after the
games and they were all terrified
because they couldn't speak out or he'd
have them killed that's so tame though
in comparison if anyone wants to go
watch it's about Hussain you should do
it it's crazy what was the dinner party
thing I mean I don't know if I should
say that on YouTube really I mean it's
only gruesome it's not about like
transsexuals or anything
yeah I think I think YouTube doesn't
actually have any hard rules on talking
about war and conflict I mean like I
mean let's just we can talk about the
cultural element in the United States
you can you can show a movie where
people's heads are exploding but right
certain defensive things are taboo you
can't talk about you can't make certain
jokes yeah I mean if you want to go
watch uh some good content on it who's
done a far better uh story on all that
is count dankula the whole thing on New
Day Hussein uh it's oh mad Lads huh yeah
madlib on them it's it's in it's in
depth it'll be much better and it's a
nice thick so it'll probably be really
funny too yeah and from what I can tell
it's a result of Saddam beating the hell
out of his kids and just being a
horrible vacant father yeah like I had a
vision of of him being like the his one
regret in life so I'm I was saying is
that he didn't spend time with his kids
that he didn't love us I feel like
that's probably that's so sweet it was
like his soul I was like that's the
cutest thing I've ever heard I pictured
him like just wishing that he could
spend time with the sunset and his
children after all was said and done
[Laughter]
I mean Ian 20s for this one you know or
is that the particular thing I don't
know we are one of the most like
empathetic and compassionate people like
yeah even even when you're referring
some of the most evil yeah you have the
most what was it I'm the most uh modest
I'm the most modest of them
have mixed feelings on taking out
dictators because like they probably
throughout history that's the economic
Hitman model you try and bribe the
country if you don't get that you try
and assassinate the leader if you don't
get that you go to war and that's what
they did in Iraq probably I think they
well they took Kuwait in what the 50s
basically they colonized a tip of it so
they could get their oil flown in and
out
I don't know I don't know about killing
a dictator I just
agree with you this and by the way I was
totally against the first Iraq war
um
to go back to 9 11 when Tim Poole had
got graduated into second grade uh I was
I was I was a freshman in high school
okay well I would have been I didn't go
to high school but you know oh goodness
no wonder you're so smart
um after something I mean we were it was
just so so out of the blue when suddenly
we figure out there's this whole region
of the world we've never even thought of
we didn't know where they existed and
they're over there hating us hating us
hating us and so
it it was different from just like
randomly searching the globe for a bad
guy to say it's not like Kim Jong-un who
cares
um
and
I might even be one over
um to your perspective even after 9 11
and wanting to have an Arab Israel so
they wouldn't be able to blame
everything I know it's the U.S it's the
US that's keeping us down
um I might even be one over just because
I what you were saying about you know
Raytheon and Boeing there it's it is
just so corrupt so corrupt guaranteed
contracts and Ukraine proves that it's
six arms manufacturers that basically
run the world's arm manufacturing I
think 140 billion on paper five of the
six are American and then Bae is British
so it's basically one big they've split
it into six companies so it doesn't look
like a monopoly yes they've got the the
global arms Monopoly right oh
incidentally you know the other thing
that proves is that no actually
Americans can manufacture things
actually we can sell things abroad now
it's a law when we sell arms to other
countries they have to buy American-made
products okay start doing that with
aspirin and masks and everything we're
buying from China and all the crap on
Amazon this idea that we can oh no
manufacturing's gone never gonna bring
it back just like the wall they're not
really trying oh we know we can do as
graphene or if you study this chemical
it's pure carbon you can get it out of
the air out of the carbon dioxide in the
air and turn into this building material
graph pure carbon it's a hexagonal
lattice so it looks like a honeycomb but
it's one atom thick it's 200 times
stronger than steel it's pure carbon
it's electrically conductive you can use
it for wiring capacitators to use it for
Batteries touch screen wallpaper you can
make buildings if you drop it this room
won't blow up right it's just it's just
it's just dust it's like carbon dust and
you can you can like mix it with other
metals to make super strong materials
lightweight electrically conducted we'll
like fix our roads with it we'll fix our
Railways with it we'll make new stronger
railroads that don't bend and cause
derailment why do you have a little jar
of Tim bought it for me as a gift
because he's obsessed with it but I will
say this it's going to be a hundred
years in the future everyone's gonna
have flying cars and jet packs
everything will be made of graphene and
there's going to be a statue of Ian in
the middle of like New York City
and when you walk up you you activate
the graphene hologram system and it was
like in 2020s Ian Crossland appearing on
Tim cast IRL began began his advocacy
for graphene a great man a smart man an
inventor graphene revolutionized the
world and brought world peace and ended
World Hunger well it'll probably create
a new a new era of conflict and con but
what one possibility is he had started
several Wars I'll be merciless it's like
Oppenheimer you know building a bomb
um we'll start pulling it out of the air
and be like this is how we solve the
climate catastrophe get the carbon
dioxide levels down we start building
but then other countries will start and
they'll be like uh oh looks like we're
about to pull too much carbon out of the
air and the trees are gonna die and
that's the next climate catastrophe so
we need some the Coalition let's jump to
the story from the post-millennial
fetterman to stay in hospital for weeks
for depression treatment senior Aid okay
so he gets admitted to the hospital
because he's lightheaded the dude had a
very serious stroke and now he's
suffering from the thing where he can't
understand words anymore he then gets
lightheaded has to go to the hospital
again now he's depressed now he can't
work so what are they gonna do so how
long until you think Biden or no it's
going to be who's the governor Shapiro
that's right how long until he appoints
Veteran's wife of Pennsylvania yes how
long until he appoints Veteran's wife to
the Senate well the good news is as far
and I hate to say this because Shapiro
wants to run for president and be the
first Jewish president
um and of all the people I've heard of
being the first Jewish president at the
moment Shapiro looks like the most
likely he's not he does not appear to be
crazy
um now he was running against
um Trump's candidate that mastriano who
was completely crazy
um you think he was crazy yes why do you
think he's crazy because he's attending
well how about just he attends Q Anon
rallies do not tell me you guys are into
Q Anon no but I messed around on the
show Once yeah I actually legalized weed
he said no so I was kind of like a
but I'm sorry Libertarians are in the
chat are going to lose it
um oh we can do that but we but we do
have to get to my comments on Nikki
Haley
um and so Federman is in the senate in
the first place never forget because of
Donald's Trump uh endorsing mastriano
and and
um who do you think Trump should have
not endorsed anyone in the Pennsylvania
race or was mastiano particularly uh
divisive to it was I mean the whole
thing basically from January 11th all of
these candidates running on 2020 being
stolen how was it that I knew a year
before the election huh he ran on One
Promise didn't keep it not gonna win
what a shocker that he didn't win of
course and he was running against you
know a guy with SEMA seen all dementia
who was a even when he was firing
on all cylinders so yeah with with with
with the crime I mean things looked
pretty good well only Trump could have
lost that election after all of the
antifa and the Looting well Republicans
didn't understand bad harvesting they
did not understand it's all true he's
lost the last three election cycles for
us yeah when he uh and the last one the
midterms oh my gosh things couldn't have
been set up more beautifully for us but
I think it's about harvesting because
well that's a very bad thing we need to
do it too
yes
um I think uh Lauren bobert's district
is a good example where she narrowly
wins by only a few hundred votes and
you're asking yourself whoa whoa whoa
whoa how does that happen this is a this
is like a rural conservative District
ballot Harvester she's kind of nutty I
think she's all right we had her on the
show I think the issue is that it
doesn't you you don't need to convince
someone to vote for you anymore they
show up knock on the door and say
Republicans are fascists right fill out
the ballot and then people go you got it
they figured out that Democrats are low
information voters and always have been
conservatives and the factions within
the right and Republican argue with each
other oh yes right so you might think
she's nutty she might think you're
naughty and you're both trying to exist
in a similar space whereas Democrats
don't know anything right and are just
told to vote and do that's what that's
why they want 16 year olds absolutely
right
so the only answer is ballot Harvest
back I guess well the answer is you
should have to show up and vote in
person fight your way past the Black
Panthers go into the ballot room
doing secret ballot I I would get rid of
all mail-in ballots and that will hurt
Republicans most of all I mean probably
we should allow states to have with an
excuse a mail-in ballot if that's not
supposed to say but the Democrats I
would even be willing to sacrifice those
and who and look make Election Day a
national holiday how about that national
holiday but you have to show up in
person because Democrats have always
cheated there are a million different
ways they cheat ballot harvesting is one
of many but understanding these were Lee
I'm doing air quotes for illegal because
the question the question is
constitutionality yes in in Pennsylvania
a lower Court ruled it was
unconstitutional to create Universal
mail-in voting but it was done with the
legislator with Republicans and
Democrats and then what happens is
Democrats imagine New York City One
activist how many doors can they knock
on in one hour when you go into one
building exactly and Republicans have to
drive I mean if you're gonna if you're
gonna go but it's more than that that's
why the what you were just saying about
how many can you knock on how many doors
can you knock on a day that's why when
they extend mail-in ballots for like six
months before the election that gives
them a lot of time they can drag their
amount of time to knock on doors you are
absolutely right about that the more
time they have and look if they wanted I
don't care they're driving people who
are you know fetterman's mentality to
the poll and tell them how to fill it
out but you got one day to do all your
cheating here's here's the the issue I
see as I've been describing in the past
couple of weeks the United States is
suffering from left left hemisphere
hypoxia
you know they say when you're on an
airplane put on your oxygen mask before
you put on the mask of the person
sitting next to you because if you
become hypoxic you become delirious and
you can't function there are these
videos where they'll put people in a in
a pressurized chamber and they'll start
lowering the oxygen percentage while
having them answer math questions oh
really the people who are becoming
hypoxic don't know there's chicken
scratching and writing gibberish garbage
their brain tells them they're correct
and then when they increase the oxygen
back to normal they go whoa wait a
minute what did I write I didn't even
realize your brain's not working so
here's what happens
the Democrats are going after what I
would describe as the hypoxic voter
seven years
about every subject yeah and they're
swimming in it so they say your body is
completely reborn every seven years
right every cell in your body has
changed every seven years these are
people whose entire existence is within
the confines of the media narrative fake
news machine lying about everything that
is the left turn hemisphere of our
country's brain
shriveled withered and hypoxic
how do you get the and there
and there the problem is you will get a
calm rational like even Bill Maher who's
a liberal will complain about wokeness
and say there's something wrong with
this he's trying to to understand but
even he is somewhat trapped in that and
those fake narratives he's going to be
in my sane liberals club right oh nice
but so how do you convince someone like
imagine this imagine you're on a plane
and all of the auction masks drop down
everyone on the right side of the plane
puts their mask on all of the mass on
the left are broken and then when the
people on the right are saying put them
put this mask on they're going get away
from me you fetched and they're swinging
at you then they say we're gonna we want
the pilot to press the emergency button
you're like no stop you're hypoxic you
don't know what you're doing
and that's what that's how I view what's
going on love that that's my analogy so
the so the issue is you get people like
saying liberals like Bill Maher people
like me people like Dave Rubin former
liberals classic liberals people who
have not found themselves to becoming
conservative you will go to traditional
liberals and desperately beg them to
please just read the article from The
New York Times that says this and they
go uh no
they're absolutely right completely
demoralized and then they will vote for
Joe Biden like that it's a very womanly
party
yeah yeah why do you think you and some
other sort of people who started left
were able to put on oxygen masks yeah
like what how come some of you are
making it out there are the same
liberals Club but a majority of people
can't well I think it has to do with
even if your oxygen mask is on the
signals from your brain can't travel to
the rest of your body if you have no
spine so for many of these people it
just didn't work there was no hope well
what I mean by that is there are a lot
of people who know they're lying there
are a lot of people who are liberal who
are just like hey man if I speak up look
I get messages all the time from people
who are like I really love your show I
respect what you do and then I say hey
man you should speak up
I I know pro athletes and they'll say
they'll message me saying like I wish I
could but I'll lose everything and I'm
like no it's true but I'm like dude you
don't need to come out and wave a trump
flag all right you simply need to come
out don't when someone says something
we'll go I don't know about all that
that's it that's all I'm saying you're
totally right they won't do it they
won't well they might you gotta shake
them some of them are I think a lot of
why you never went crazy and like to
answer your question why some people
don't get hypoxic mentally is um like
high altitude training if you're
constantly working the muscle you're
kind of able to resist that's a that's a
good point yeah so for for me I was
traveling around I was doing news I was
going to Trump rallies so when a story
would come aren't they fun they were fun
and Trump's a comedian he's hilarious so
not so funny anymore not any he's lost
it he's doesn't have that same comedic
uh and some people still really like
what he's saying but I do think he's
lost a bit of it
um or a lot of it I should say but I
would go to a trump rally and then I
would talk with a trump supporter and I
remember I'm in Fort Lauderdale this is
2016. right 2016. yeah that was great
I'm in Fort Lauderdale and I'm talking
to a woman I was thinking I was living
in Miami and she I think yeah so maybe
it might have been 2015. and she says
I've never voted before I'm not a
republican I'm an independent but Trump
seems he's the only person talking about
issues that that affect me and my family
so then I would go to The Newsroom at
fusion and they would say Trump is
courting white supremacists and I would
go no the lady I met was like a
construction worker or something and
they're like that's not true they're all
Nazis they're all racist and I was like
no I'm pretty sure that lady in Florida
was just like some right one of the one
of the ladies I talked to was Hispanic
no no no no no oh Hispanics loved him in
2016. especially in Florida yes I spend
Christmas in in Palm Beach and I I was
going around to Christmas parties 2000
oh this is 2015 and so when he first
announced and
and Wilbur Ross who has a place in Palm
Beach he was like wandering around like
a zombie Starstruck and he kept going up
to everyone at these Christmas parties
saying I don't understand it we're all
for Jeb and the Hispanic help is all for
Trump
trump I I I met a lot of Hispanic people
uh in Florida who are just like we know
what socialism is man Bernie scares us
and I'm like that's not surprising to me
you know 2016 I thought
um my full
um it was like a full-time job going
around to bars in New York and
convincing Bernie supporters that they
had to vote for Trump full-time job job
or full-time hobby because I feel like I
would have so much fun doing that
well you can love yourself but but
between I mean among the three of them
actually among all the candidates Bernie
and Trump were the closest at least in
what Trump said yeah Trump was great on
the campaign Trail I mean I still didn't
expect him to win I thought for sure the
comp military complex had him down
Hillary had it and then when he when he
won I was like like knocked out of
breath but then he went on script right
after he got elected he started reading
off a prompt and that he hadn't done it
the entire time he was running and I was
like this guy's just a sham isn't it
he's just a fake and then he made John
Bolton one of his dudes the war machine
moved on he did get us out of
trans-pacific partnership I think he I
don't know if he realized the level that
the liberal economic order was planning
to become the New World Order no no no
it's not like don't give me the oh we
try this you know too bad he wasn't
president he didn't try he didn't care
he wanted to sit in bed and tweet that
trans-pacific partnership I never told
anyone this because I'm very
um I'm I'm a vault if if I talk to a
politician but it it leaks like two
months later later so I can say it now I
went to see Trump like February
of 2017 after he was elected and I just
stood at the Resolute desk and yelled at
him for 15 minutes and I didn't use the
f word first but once he used it ooh was
that flying so I think the entire West
Wing heard and that's how it eventually
leaked but trans-pacific partnership I
said what are you doing what are you
doing where is it you haven't done any
you're not starting on the wall you
haven't done anything with trans-pacific
partnership and he he didn't know we
didn't care Kim Kardashian was his next
appointment did you feel like that was
the problem with Trump's uh time in
office that he didn't have enough people
pushing him yeah
the people he brought in Jared Kushner
look he ran for president before at this
point Tim Poole was in sixth grade when
Trump first ran for president 2000.
I don't know when was he running on no
because it was uh it was Obama Reform
Party right yeah and what did he run on
he ran on
um Obama not being born in this country
than I am mind you
it doesn't work the three elections
since 2016 haven't worked activating the
crazies this way that way that the
election was stolen
um the one time he won was when he ran
on my book adios America
it was just something he thought that
might work
and so he ripped off the arguments in a
rather stupid and ignorant way still he
was making the arguments I would write
in Trump We Trust again because given
the options but he believes none of it
he understands none of it of course he
could have fired my question is who gave
him your book right like I feel like he
must have at least we might want people
but who was like you should read this
book it's a good idea right because it
would I think it was wrong he knew when
he ran and I was making fun of him on
the on the when he ran the first time on
the Obama birth certificate one of my
friends was a reporter in New York and
he said he's reporting on Trump and
they're all and he was threatening to
run for president he's talking about the
Obama birth certificate and my friend
um I think it was New York Times
Reporter anyway he emailed me and said
everybody else who says you're wrong
about the birth certificate he's
denouncing he's calling these horrible
names and somebody yelled out hey Ann
Coulter says
um
whatever I had said about him being
completely wrong it was a crazy idea and
my friend said he started to attack
because that was the mode he was in
oh I know what it was it was
specifically Ann Coulter says you're
never going to run and he starts to do
the attack and then pulled back and said
well she'll just have to wait and see so
he knew to be careful about Crossing me
even back then and he had invited me to
lunch which I went to only because I
wanted when I walk on the beach in Palm
Beach to jump over and go in the
swimming pool
um and so he had been appealing to me he
I think he had just like this animal
sense of she says things that are
popular with Americans yeah interesting
but I think that was the end of it he
obviously did not care about immigration
but he so he didn't come through with
his immigration platforms but was
polling pretty well up until kovid do
you think that the American public also
forgot that he had promised to do all
these things I mean no I think the only
votes Trump got were were opposition
votes really to Biden and the craziness
and antifa and and black lives matter
and even though he all he did was tweet
Law and Order exclamation point at least
he's not these people yeah but the black
lives matter summer was like pretty
crazy that wasn't enough to push him
over the edge you didn't well a he
didn't do anything yeah he couldn't he
should have brought in the military yeah
he should have Portland especially after
100 days of firebombing a federal
building and he didn't do anything about
it they burned down the police precincts
in Minneapolis and and these and by the
way who suffers the most
um people in the bad neighborhoods I
agree I can't get down with anyone
that's platform is that's bad that's
that's worse so put me in like for why
give me your a reason to live yes you
know not just a reason to push death
away yeah I want to pull up uh your sub
stack and we have this uh Ann Coulter
substack unsafe you have this this is a
really interesting letter from the New
York Times executive editor Joe Khan to
staff writing about what happened with
the the trans uh rights activists and
leftist activists coming after them but
uh do you want to give us the gist of it
and it was leaked Jimmy I was the first
one to send it out
um
I mean I know this from other reporters
at the New York Times that they they do
still have some serious journalists who
know how to do journalism they're very
smart they're very skilled but then I
don't know a few years ago they brought
in all the worksters and it's just like
this cloud of locusts who go around
attacking people who are doing the
actual job of putting a newspaper out
and the the executive editor is this guy
jokon
um I looked him up on Wikipedia very
impressive person he's old style New
York Times which I disagreed with it was
liberal but it was written well and they
didn't lie
um the crazy thing this letter he's
sending it around because actual I guess
reporters and editors and probably HR
Representatives at the New York Times
have signed on to this letter
representing the trans people attacking
the New York Times for its coverage of
trans issues and it's a very gentle
letter but it is him standing up to the
welksters saying you can't be an
activist and attacking people at the
organization you work for and that's the
gist of the letter which shows that
there are still some same people at the
New York Times and who knows and as soon
as they retire yeah yeah the woke people
take over and then the New York Times I
wouldn't be surprised if they changed
their name to like you know down with
whiteness times right.org or something
the only reason I think they wouldn't is
because it's such an institution and
they get to say we are the oldest
newspaper and therefore we are the
authority newspaper of record yeah right
yeah
one of my commenters on on the sub stack
said if you didn't do this for a living
would you subscribe to the New York
Times
and I thought about it no no I'd read
The Daily Mail every day they have 10
million members paying what like 10
bucks a month
some ridiculous I mean in some ways it
is the leading newspaper in America
right people think of it first when they
think it's just fake yeah I mean they
people are it's it would be better to
subscribe to your local newspaper and
get actual news from people who know
what's going on in your life if you want
to feel like you are I mean some stuff
is going to be AP but local crime for
example that's going to be yeah or Daily
Mail right things that will impact your
life you need someone who's actually
reporting on them and I think people
instead see it as like oh well I'm I'm
an informed intellectual I I list I read
the uh New York Times I mean I know some
people who very well intentions will
tell me oh I listened to the New York
Times Daily podcast and that's where I
get a lot of my news and they're they're
doing an honest effort to be informed
right but it's hard to then look at them
be like but that's not the one you got
tomtimcast.com I do all the time I know
well they do still have some good
reporters but you really have to
search for and it isn't that strange
that you have to search for the good
reporter and I think leaders are often
you know sucking some of the information
out for example the race of any black
criminal oh in Sweden it's crazy I
remember uh when I was covering the news
covering the big story in Sweden when
Trump came out and said last night in
Sweden I went there they actually not
only would they blur the the skin of the
criminal they would alter the pixel
color to make it seem like it was a
white person who got blurred
oh that's crazy huh
it's like dude come on that's that's
more racist in my opinion wow yeah going
it's it's all just still racism the idea
that you can't like the they were
basically saying the population could
not handle learning that not white
people would commit crimes yeah like any
person can commit a crime dude come on
that's what they do that's what they do
and that's putting a lot of girls at
risk oh yeah yeah yeah did you go like
fully independent now are you you're
totally independent at the moment well I
always have been oh so you just like
never worked I mean since I left I sent
a Judiciary Committee basically are you
gonna write another book
because you know I'd love to ask you
guys for one thing I've written 13 books
all New York Times bestsellers they're
excellent books they yes thanks to
Vanessa My Fabulous this is sitting here
um
I think I for one thing I think I've
said it all I mean mugged is about crime
it's the I've said it all immigration
Trump we in Trump We Trust I'm telling
you that is a great book even though he
turned out to be a grifter and a liar
um what he was what he was saying and
doing was great
um demonic on the French Revolution on
Mob Behavior about antifa I don't think
there's any better explanation of that
treason the history of of a lot of our
Wars
um if you wanted to know about
impeachment I don't think there's you
wouldn't write about DeSantis you
wouldn't write about well I need a point
I don't write oh when he was born in
there's got to be an over a point that I
don't think people know and I I think
every one of these books guilty about
the victimology culture and everybody
wanting to be a victim he was offended
first wins
um there's so much great stuff in that
books that anything that is a large
topic I've already written about it
which is more than I thought I was going
to write I thought I was done after my
third book and after every book until
that's it I got nothing else you thought
you were done after your third book and
then 10 books later now God always said
to me you say that after every book
publishers giving you a hard time with
uh the topics that you choose or do you
find that you get free reign because you
are such an established you know
intellectual well my second book that
um
your older listeners may have heard me
say this
um my the the the story in book
publishing is you don't make money on
your first bestseller you make it on the
advance to your next book well my first
book out of the gate High crimes and
misdemeanors it was a New Year's Times
bestseller and for quite a while
um
and I couldn't get a second book
published
at a publisher I wrote the book my
editor died he was magnificent I
dedicated the book to him
um and the publisher Harper Collins
Rupert Murdoch Brook Collins took the
opportunity to cancel the book and I had
you know the star agent Joni Evans she
was the Hotshot book agent she's
shopping it around to all of her Pals on
Publishers Row in New York City and they
absolutely would not publish a book by
me and she'd send me their emails back
back to me saying things like
Ouija my second book was slander about
liberal laws about the American right a
lot about the media man that's a good
book
um and they'd write to her we do not
think this would move the public
dialogue forward what and I'd emailed
Joni back saying you know that's so
weird because I thought Publishers made
money on the basis of how many books
sold not Matt how many inches they moved
the public dialogue for and anyway it
was the number one book All Summer One
Crown publishing finally published it
and I taunted Publishers row all year
there's always going to be something to
write about because now with like defund
the police with crime running rampant
the next all in mugged well but I just
mean like the next thing's gonna come
soon right the left will come out with
some some new insane policy idea and
then yeah I'd be like oh heaven's made
time to write a book have you or would
you update audios America because
immigration is not getting better in
fact I think every word is perfect but
you wouldn't I'm sorry I'm sounding like
Ian now
as always you wouldn't update it with a
new chapter after after a Biden term
Biden let in 5 million illegals I think
it the book is perfect it's like going
back and trying actually the Mona Lisa
isn't that great
it's wonderful and it's Simplicity
I don't know Trump talks you know in its
crude fashion it's not crude it's that
um
uh unlike apparently everyone as we
found out today who works for Fox I say
what I think is true I mean this is my
intro letter to sub stack I didn't
mention any particular conservative
network but it's all about being on TV
and having a job and okay you may not
like what I'm saying and maybe sometimes
I'm wrong
um but you can always be sure that I am
saying what I believe to be true we now
have all of the fox hosts saying they
knew Trump's election claims were BS
they knew it was crazy they thought
Giuliani was out of his mind and Cindy
Powell was out of her mind and they're
going on TV and presenting it to the
viewers so I blame Fox News as much as
Trump for what's happened to the
Republican party and why who was it that
was saying did you say you have
you have friends who it was January 6th
they say they'll never vote Republican
again no it wasn't me oh maybe it was
downstairs maybe downstairs because of
the way it was handled people say
they'll never vote Republican it was so
out no that it was outrageous that it
even happened they are blaming
Republicans for that well why did it
happen why is it still happening because
and I look some of these people are my
friends and conservative talk radio and
TV and I yell at them all the time they
say oh when we have you on you know
ratings go down everybody's mad
everybody writes in they're so they're
oh don't believe that I fundamentally do
not believe that when you go on their
ratings go down well not ratings go down
but they get a lot of hate mail well
sorry no it it is the most listened to
of the show is MSNBC inviting you want
to talk bad about Trump
no no you have to say the same but
well I think what happened the reason
they feel like they're getting more
viewers and they're getting less hate
mail is
after the 2020 election I I have TV on
in every room of my house to MSNBC so
that I can just walk through the room
and hit the mute button and never miss
anything they say even I couldn't listen
to it after for a it's very repetitive
but B once Biden wins Democrats have the
house Democrats have the Senate it's
like do I want to see you know Moment by
moment report on a slow-motion plane
crash there's nothing we can do we're
being gonna be strangled to death until
it gets fun until young and ran until
DeSantis is running then it'll be fun
again so I think normal people and I'm
not even normal and I couldn't watch
political news I was just watching
Forensic Files so the only people I
think still tuning into cable news
are the are the Trump Fanatics let me
let me pull up the story from the
guardian this is uh Fox News hosts
thought Trump's election fraud claims
were total BS it's a quote court filings
show comments by Tucker Carlson Sean
Henry and Laura Ingram revealed in 1.6
billion Dominion defamation lawsuit
blah blah blah quote he's acting like an
insane person Hannity allegedly wrote of
trump in the weeks following the
elections even billionaire Fox owner
Robert Murdoch I don't think it's
allegedly did they write allegedly yeah
they were allegedly it's in the
documents he says meanwhile Carlson one
of the Network's most prominent and
controversial Stars was disdainful of
Sydney Powell a senior Trump attorney
who repeatedly claimed dominions
machines flipped votes cast uh for Trump
to Biden but didn't uh he says City Paul
is lying he wrote to a producer the
Dominion lawsuit alleges he referred to
Powell in a text as an unguided missile
and dangerous as hell didn't Tucker get
get attacked because he was critical of
Sydney pollen says the guardian piece is
telling the story right I read it on NBC
and Forbes and I thought I thought axios
I think had it first and no they're
they're very direct quotes showing that
they were what they were telling their
viewers is not what they believed and
they are doing that still today acting
like oh Trump he's the greatest he tried
to build the wall
but I think I think Tucker got and all
of them off camera 100 agree with me on
Trump and I say why won't you say this
on radio why are you leaving me out
there all alone like I'm the nut against
Trump when you know damn well I'm right
we're at my dinner table you're telling
me this
oh because yeah they'll get mad at us I
just I have to I have to break it to
them slowly don't worry Anne it's coming
it's coming okay that's why you need to
follow me on sub stack you can learn it
from me first and not be lied to do you
feel like that's the fate of news media
today like you have to find independent
people who are operating on Independent
platforms what is it sure seems like it
so what do you how do you get your news
you say that you keep up with them not
safe for work sites oh yeah
uh and podcasts probably you guys that
but you're safe for work
well I mean not completely sometimes
people swear that's not where you work
we we tell people the rules of swearing
it's like a guideline not a roof you
swear well you know it's just that some
people have their kids in the room
probably right the problem is Sydney
Powell and and Giuliani and all these
people made is they made definitive
claims about things they suspected I
never saw the evidence I believe if a
proprietary voting machine is tallying
votes in secret and we can't watch the
algorithm that's deciding how the votes
are coming out that's a problem because
we can't confirm if they did it for real
or if they cheated and flipped the votes
we don't know but to say that they
cheated you better have the evidence you
better have the proof here because
that's a defamation I mean obviously my
definition my issue is that I think did
you read the article from Time Magazine
the shadow campaign to fortify the
election or whatever
famous let me let me oh I heard about
this yeah let me let me try and pull
this one up
Time Magazine oh they just the secret
history of the Shadow campaign I'm not
gonna log in let me see if I can just do
this the secret history of the Shadow
campaign that saved the 2020 election is
what they called it and they talk about
all of the procedural changes they
enacted to benefit Democrats they did
that right in front of our eyes
everybody could see it happening and
they did it through a legal process yeah
that some argued was unconstitutional
and we didn't get that adjudicated the
problem I had is early on after the
election everybody was talking about
Dominion they were talking about hacking
voting systems they're talking about
watermarked ballots China sending in
fake ballots all of these things and I'm
like this is crazy yep they were talking
about Donald Trump getting reinstated on
March 8th like the true date of
inauguration yes not gonna happen yes
and then they got mad at me not a thing
everybody but some people got mad at me
saying Tim is is refusing to accept it
now that I'm still in the exact same
place where I'm like yes they changed
the rules they changed the laws and
that's a problem now people are going so
you finally agree with us on the
elections hey Tim and I'm like no people
people were saying that Trump was going
to get inaugurated in secret and that
Biden some people were arguing that
Biden was was in on it with Trump and
that he was acting as a dummy present in
a fake White House to protect Trump I'm
like none of that is true yes and then
people will still say how did Joe Biden
get 81 million votes uh they sent out 81
million they probably sent out a hundred
yeah they probably said about 300
million ballots right and then crossed
their fingers they set up in Wisconsin
they had those those boxes you could
just go and dump stuff Wisconsin I think
later ruled it unconstitutional but then
it got reversed or something like that
in Pennsylvania they defied their own
Constitution the legislature got
together and they they were about to
enact a universal mail-in vote voting
stopped because they realized the
Constitution required them to actually
have it on in a newspaper on the ballot
so then they changed the wording somehow
and pushed it through anyway Republicans
negotiated that deal with Democrats a
year before the 2020 election all of
that procedural stuff happened how did
Joe Biden get all those votes people
weren't voting for Joe Biden they were
voting against Trump yes Democrats did
things like voting in the park where
they were like oh our vote our polling
stations are overflowing so go to the
park they did things like knocking on
somewhere vote in the park that it
happened I'm pretty sure it happened all
over I don't uh but I know for sure
there was a big issue with Wisconsin
there was a lawsuit specifically about
whether or not it was they were legal uh
it was it was constitutional to do this
ultimately what did they fill out the
absentee ballot in the park or did they
move the machines to the park they've
like set up voting locations in the park
something like that because I think it
was absenteen you drop it in a box or
something on the fly on the election day
they said it's too crowded here and you
should set up here well let me make sure
I have the specifics because it's been a
really long time since it doesn't even
matter because you were right the
changed rule tools for covet are things
liberals have been trying to do for 20
years and they used covet as an excuse
to push it through and it wasn't
Dominion that's the kind of argument
that the left makes and that they did
make again so incidentally they've
contested every elect presidential
election they've lost this Century it's
true every single one I do think Ian's
right applicants are the are the bad
ones yeah but this is the first one we
contested with all new voting rules
whomever lost this election and it was
obviously going to be Trump whomever
whichever side lost was going to be
ticked off about this election you can't
give create all new rules that have
never existed before and not expect the
losing side to be ticked off we should
have been ticked off and you're
completely right it was the new coveted
rules but but and they've persisted and
so I think yes they have yes they have
the midterm election everyone's shocked
how is this possible that all the polls
show Republicans should have swept but
then it was an it was a narrow Victory
and it's because likely voters don't
matter anymore the pollsters that's a
great Point yeah they're looking for
people who they think are likely to vote
not realizing that that 20 year old kid
who's playing OverWatch in his in his
living room knock on the door and he
gets up and he's like what election and
they're like did you felt your bed is
like no and they're like we're gonna
keep coming your house and knocking on
your door until you fill that out okay
fine I'll fill it out what do I do there
you go have get out get out right or mom
comes home and she goes did you fill out
your balance it's no Mom I don't care
fill out your balance so you're not
getting lunch money and then the kids
fill it out or the inverse the woke
college student shows up and says mom if
you vote for Donald Trump I swear okay
honey fine I'll vote for Joe Biden and
then she fills it out that's the kind of
thing Democrats did and the nursing
homes and and and going into nursing
homes and here's getting John fetterman
types there was uh I think it was in
Pennsylvania I'm not sure which state it
was where this was recently it was like
the AG said it's legal to ballot harvest
in nursing homes all they have to do is
sign a consent form and allow the
individual who walks in to be their
caretaker yeah so I'm telling people in
I think more than half the country about
harvesting is legal Democrats are going
nuts saying we don't care if they want
us in the office all that matters they
sign their name yes so people are
wondering why why why did Biden get so
many votes but down ballot it didn't
because the people who are filling this
out don't know don't care they're just
filling out Biden and nothing else
because you're getting activists going
door-to-door saying vote for Biden and
they don't know anything anything else
about these other candidates but if you
if anything was going to be done about
it it had to be done before the election
sending out tweets saying oh this is
going to be unfair that's not going to
do it and right now Republicans need to
be doing everything they can to prepare
for 2024 cleaning up the voter rolls
cleaning up the voter rules what people
need to understand about Rhonda Santos
winning in Florida there everyone wants
the narrative to be his policies are so
popular he swung a a blue a purple State
red with a million point with a million
vote lead when in reality there's two
big things he did one his policies
attracted all of the moderate to
conservative individuals around the
country to flee to Florida massively
increasingly
but he also cleaned up the state in
terms of how voting is done yes so they
they they reverted a lot of these rules
they cleaned up the rules yeah I
wouldn't behold DeSantis wins yes yes
absolutely right that's what we got to
do that's another hit he has that's why
I say he's given us everything but if
he's going to win in 2024 if he's gonna
if he is gonna need all these states to
do it yes you're absolutely right and
not complain about Dominion the the I I
don't like proprietary machines secretly
tallying votes we that should be an Open
Source process where people can verify I
talked to Matt Gates about it um and
he's full on interested in blockchain as
a verification for our votes so like you
still make your vote in person via paper
or whatever but it's tallied on some or
multitude of digital you know immutable
systems where we can like
cross-reference that the votes still
exactly what you want it what you intend
for it to be because if you just hand
your vote to a corporation or anybody
that does it in the back room in secret
and then sends out the tally afterwards
like that's not secure I don't I'm not
saying that they cheated but the coveted
rules are the big problem do you think
that there's a single major issue going
into 2024 like you personally believe
immigration is the number one
immigration crime and I think think I
could be wrong about this but I think
what they did to us over covid is still
going to be big I wanna I'm still bitter
anybody sufferings who sent their their
kids to school were Mass their kids you
know they weren't getting enough oxygen
the businesses don't have their growth
businesses went bankrupt I think
and that was what led so many people to
move to Florida
I gotta do I got to do a quick quick
yeah quick correction I got to do a
quick correction on uh on the on the Fox
News thing everyone's ragging on all
these these personalities but I have the
Tweet right here from uh November 2020
Tucker Carlson said quote he would give
Sydney Powell the whole hour on a show
but she refused to provide evidence and
told them to stop contacting her no I
was saying I think you at the guarding
and had a bad quote from the secret
documents yeah yeah no no I was just
saying because yes on that one he did
say that but there were other he got
roasted for it but that that's not the
point the point is he was also raising
well
there were other quotes suggesting that
he thought the whole thing was crazy and
Trump was bad well yeah but on his show
he said I'm not going to forget Sydney
Powell drop Sydney talking about her he
did a show talking about the whole
election fraud narrative where he was
basically like it's not true there's no
evidence she's making it up
she right right she he's using her in
the context of this is not I'm gonna I'm
gonna go get my computer and get the NBC
article they were all saying that yeah
that they were still talking about Trump
and maybe there's something to this not
the Sydney Powell particularly yeah she
was the craziest of them all can I I
have a different question do you mind if
I oh yeah uh what do you think of the
effort to impeach mayorkas do you think
it's going to work do you think he's
gonna resign because when McCarthy was
trying to become speaker he had the
whole or anything Cruz wrote a letter to
saying either you uh resign now because
you've done such a terrible job or you
are I like it a lot better than Hunter
Biden's laptop
who cares they've got to stop this
nonsense nobody like we didn't get we
didn't
Benghazi was a disaster for for our side
um I think Russia was a disaster for
their side this endless investigation
could you get something done we're out
we're dying out here so hearings that
are toward something toward a policy
change past immigration laws impeach my
orcas yeah I think that would be great
do you think that my other question for
you is so we just released Biden's
Health document they say he's fit and
ready to serve do you believe that do
you think Biden is healthy no I think
it's really obvious to everyone yeah I
mean Democrats so who do you think the
Democrats are going to field in 2024
exactly where I was going
Weekend at Bernie's really I think they
have to I mean I could look I could be
wrong he could die he could maybe they
can't even do wheat but they have the
whole media behind them so they can get
away with anything do you think they'll
run them they can do another fake coven
and say oh we can't have debates coven
they have the media the Legacy Media
have so much power
and the reason I think they do Weekend
at Bernie's is
take Biden out who do they got
um a he's a white male yep
um I think I maybe these will be famous
last words I think he's Preposterous
candidate and what he's done to that
state
um no I actually go very quickly to AOC
Elon Omar I think they're all the ones
that you would consider well actually he
might not be that bad they're all white
men so they're not running a white man I
think it would be really funny to see
AOC as president because she'd probably
rip all her hair out over the foreign
policy stuff she'd lose her mind she's
not she's she is not mentally capable of
dealing with foreign
Brooklyn Bronx AOC yeah I I look man
show her a photograph of what's going on
in Yemen and she's going to be like I
don't want to do this job can you
imagine AOC meeting with Vladimir Putin
like President AOC meets President Putin
I don't know maybe that's crazy to me
but I mean look my point is more so when
when they go to her and say here's the
photos of the Sarah here's a video of
the sarin gas attack what would you have
oh you believed her crying photo at the
cage no no I think she could cry and she
can be a social media influencer but you
put her and you show her real conflict
and she will literally cry and say I
don't want to do this anymore it was a
mistake yeah or you'd be like hey so
what are we going to do with Lockheed
what where are those 60 billion she
freaked out because a cop knocked on her
door remember that story from January
6th right but that's all their phoniness
you think aoc's strong enough to handle
a modicum of foreign policy I think that
I think Democrats are absolutely
bloodless if if they saw you be if she
saw you be decapitated right here right
now I think she'd give a nice little
smile I'm I don't think so I think she
no I don't think she'd throw up I think
she'd Panic so I think you're talking
about Oliver oh the children in cages
and I'm so afraid I I I see
AOC is a I agree she's a millennial
influencer who lives right but she lives
in the pastel safe spaces world of of
wokeness these people cry because they
have to work eight hours on the weekends
you see that video of that woman well
I'm not contesting that they're up there
but so you you ask her to carry a heavy
box and she's gonna really freak out oh
she'll fake cry about immigrants ask her
to do work and she'll start bawling her
eyes out I also did we're gonna have and
don't want to have a girl president no
and I think it'll happen
um how about my Nikki Haley oh yes girl
presidents uh let me see here we go you
guys ready and I haven't heard this from
NBC News Ann Coulter tells Nikki Haley
now play the segment well people got to
know the context yes well that's just
lies right so so okay so Ann says
they're lying they're they're claiming
you said you told Nikki Haley to go back
to your own country in a racist rant
against the new GOP Presidential
candidate uh I don't I don't know if I
can actually open this though because
it's like you can't play it okay no here
we go leftovers
that's a good point I agree with that
now Nikki Haley I went this whole speech
yesterday anybody's ever known her
worked with her will tell you she's the
most ruthless treacherous backstabbing
snake in the world but then all these
political people are calling me and
saying what does that have to do with
anything that's perfect for politics
that's not a disqualification to run
what do you think
um that none of those words would have
been the word I'd use for her mine is is
shorter and simpler
okay uh she's an absolutely ridiculous
character and the only people say they
support are people who probably
genuinely are
um sexists and oh I support the girl oh
good for you you like girls
um no she's utterly completely
preposterously ridiculous uh I don't
think she will get more than two percent
of the vote
um and you know how I hate making
predictions about things like that but
she's just a Preposterous creature
um but her candidacy did remind me that
I need to immigrate to India so I can
demand they start taking down
um parts of their history
well you are a good person worshiping
what's the worshiping of the cows
they're all starving over there and
they're worshiping cows do you know they
have a a a a a rat Temple
where they worship wrath what's that is
that true hey baby cakes why don't you
go back to your own country and
reconsider that history about Gandhi's
Behavior with little girls can we
realize
as you may know I am referring to Nikki
Haley
um
um child of immigrants governor of of
South Carolina who immediately
um after you know some some psychopath
the mass shooting at the church yeah
yeah hideous oh what will I do let's
take down the Confederate flag from from
the South Carolina uh Capital as you
know Mark Simone I am descended from
Union Soldiers it's my history this is
my country lady I'm not an American
Indian and I don't like them taking down
all the monuments well I consider The
Monuments and so so the article makes it
seem by cutting out all the contacts
that you said go back to your country
lady yeah when what you were saying was
if you're going to take down our history
why don't you go look at what your
country is doing with them I'm going to
immigrate to India and demand they take
down any cow statues
he said why don't you go back to your
own country and consider that history
yeah so I I would I would my argument
would be it doesn't sound like you're
saying go back to your country you're
saying visit your country
specifically and I go on to talk about
the Indians I'm also you know unlike
Elizabeth Warren I'm not an Indian that
is part of American History we should
Revere it and I do Revere it and we do
Revere it
um you're saying basically be aware of
your own Heritage before you start
tearing down someone else's well no this
is my country and these are parts of it
and I'm really getting sick of having
our history
stripped and and and lied about but just
taken away I mean should we take down
the statue of Sitting Bull he killed a
lot of white Europeans lots of them and
then he stored with Buffalo Bill and
Annie Oakley and yeah it's like a game
kind of a celebrity and a hero
um and yeah you could say he was he was
a monster and he and he just murdered
all of these people
um no it's part of our history we have a
really cool country with a really cool
history and like I say I'm descended
from people on the union side but the
Civil War and the Confederacy there's a
reason both Indians and Confederates are
actually very similar this way they are
admired by Americans for their courage
and honor both of them even though well
some Indians were lovely and peaceful
and they couldn't they were so happy the
Europeans got here they had their their
big badass European friends with guns to
protect from them from the other Indians
who were slaughtering them
um yeah et cetera yeah yeah yeah
um that's that's why I mean why were the
Wampanoag over on the coast so that we
could celebrate Thanksgiving with them
because they had been driven there by
the Iroquois they're like hanging on for
dear life and oh Europeans show up and
you guys got guns but having said that
and just beastly animalistic savagery
that some of the Indian tribes practice
at the same time
it's really cool that that that some of
these same very Savage tribes had a rule
that you had to look at your opponent in
the eye as he's killing you as he's
torturing you you would throw abuse at
him there's something so Macho and cool
about that and that's why so many
Americans like Elizabeth Warren lie and
claim to be Indians that's why sports
teams are named after Indians that's why
so much of our military
armaments the Apache they're named after
Indians and it's the same thing with the
Confederates yeah it was a losing cause
the men fighting didn't have slaves it
was an utterly backward feudal system if
they had won we'd be a third world
country right now
um but the men who fought
there'd be two countries it would they
were
so crazily Brave when they reenact
Gettysburg which they're probably not
allowed to do anymore every year
the Union Soldiers this was I don't know
five ten years ago they were so overcome
with the courage of of the Confederate
soldiers who who are just giving up
their lives and got slaughtered
slaughtered slaughtered that both the
Union Soldiers and their
the reenactors they're all crying about
the courage of the Confederates we
admire them for courage and honor and
the guys fighting didn't have slaves
give me a break I think it was like what
five percent of the South had slaves
there were a lot of landowners that
didn't have to go do the fighting
themselves yes yes it was a lot like the
illegal immigrant you know cheap workers
today I might
um at the beginning of adios Amir this
is the last thing you'll say about this
at the beginning of adios America I'd
like chapter one I have a quote from
Louis Brandeis
liberal Jewish Supreme Court Justice
describing and I don't remember this off
the top of my head but I remember the
concept of it he said when you become an
American citizen it's more than learning
um the Customs the rules the Pledge of
Allegiance the laws you must love this
country with all of your heart it is it
should be a part of you and I feel that
way I know immigrants who feel that way
I do Nikki Haley isn't one of them from
South Africa hey you're not from here
either I was an anchor baby I was born
here the reason we're going to worship
uh cows in India is because out of their
poop cow poop grows psilocybin mushrooms
the mushrooms yeah ancient history like
way back yeah thousands of years
that's not true so if you have another
reason yes I do I do and it's okay so uh
I I they don't eat them what I learned
from a friend of mine who's and from
India is that they don't because cows
produced milk and they used that for all
of their food in production and killing
the cow
restricted your ability to produce you
know Christmas is also a it's a I'm
Anita muscaria tradition of the shaman
getting mushrooms and then drying them
out above the fireplace and socks
white you know if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and become a member at
timcast.com because guess what we
actually do have a members on the
uncensored show we already recorded it
we recorded the pre-show setup while we
were talking about God and some other
things that will pop up on the front
page of timcast.com at 10 pm so that'll
be available for you guys to watch as
members and uh excuse me let's read some
super chats Yeah Tim I think we should
do more of those by the way I think
that's like a really good opportunity
yeah on Fridays maybe yeah specifically
for instance yes we should we should
consider that all right I'm not your
buddy guy says please help me escape
Canada our country ruled today that the
use of wartime measures against the
truckers was not only lawful but
appropriate help me
not everyone I'm not your I'm not your
friend guy if you have evil laws you
kind of have a duty to bypass them I
think the trucker thing was so
incredible what they did in Canada I
feel like we should never stop talking
about it and I'm sorry that Canada hates
you and hates freedom I guess all right
miles kinslow says Hey guys wish
everyone well if Ann Coulter ran for
office what would her slogan be
call tickets results
culture gets results yes oh yeah well
there you go is that is that going to be
your slogan when you when you run
Vanessa's over there pitching as her
like campaign manager you said you said
we don't want to want a lady president
so you don't you don't think you would
be you know when people tell me to run
for president I say I don't think there
should be a woman press and you're
against women voting too right yes
well yeah the guys on the shower
this comes up we hear I feel like a
tense room where you guys are like
they're saying it why are they saying
that oh I don't care don't strip the
right to vote for my daughter my future
daughter now she has the right to vote
but she sentient just like I am
I just think it's funny that you you
like the you guys are like we should not
be allowed to vote and I'm like okay
well no I'm not giving up my book the
other ladies have to but if they give it
up I I will sacrifice my vote but they
have to stop you know you know what
would happen to this country if every
woman didn't vote yeah so we'd never
have a Democrat president yeah you'd
never have a Democrat anything the the
polls show that if only men vote only
Washington and Oregon are blue
everything else is red everywhere and
the men there are kind of do you have
aspirations to dive into politics
no no no no no I want to as on the on
the drive up here today I was talking to
one of my friends was haranguing me
because he couldn't get me on the phone
saying you will do only four things in
life sleep more sleep
skiing and I don't even remember what
the fourth thing was
um sleeping while you ski so I like my
life plan is yes to take lots of naps
roll over send a tweet and have
President DeSantis do it well there you
go all right Clint Torres says Tim
typically you have my undivided
attention but Stargate the movie came on
so I'm going to be a bit distracted
tonight Ian great show on pop culture
crisis today thanks homie Stargate is
good Stargate sg1 is way better but the
movie's all right you know
Amos Moses says The Boondocks parody was
hilarious I'm sorry
what was that they parodied you The
Boondocks I thought they were talking
about something you did yeah yeah they
did it on The Boondocks I think they did
a feature of you on The Boondocks it's a
show from like way back when now
this is what happens when you're wildly
successful and famous for telling the
truth pretty much Miss sale Fraga says
Ann Coulter is anti-immigrant not just
illegals
correct naughty I mean no that is not
really correct I'm kind of joking by
saying yes to that but
um because I will bet you compared to
not only everyone in this room but the
person who just wrote that I have more
actual immigrant friends
um have dated more immigrants have gone
to more immigrant weddings so immigrant
is the wrong way of putting it I am
against illegal immigration I think
legal immigration is way too high way
too high and why because I care about
protecting American jobs I mean we're
shipping all of our jobs to China and
um Macau and Mexico and and bringing in
people who will work for last I mean the
H-1B visa holders
they as I describe in adios America they
are doing just ordinary Computing work
we tell American citizens stem stem you
got to go to college major and stem
that's where the future is and then we
give all the cheap job the the ex or
cheap labor to do the stem jobs now why
would Apple want to hire a bunch of
Indians as opposed to a bunch of
Americans because it's indentured
servitude you are attached to the
company that brings you in and so if if
it Apple can abuse you underpay you if
Google gives you a better offer you
can't go it is we banned indentured
servitude and this is how they get
around it's a modern workaround it's
crazy yes yes it is so that's why I
think legal immigration needs to come
way down and also we just have a very
very high immigrant population I think
it's very dangerous to have these
um you are supposed to you know they
call it a Melting Pot you're supposed to
melt would you be open to an immigration
moratorium I couldn't do it but I called
for the last chapter I said five years
but that was really a trick I wanted do
you think 20 years would you do you
think DeSantis would uh enact one I mean
do you think there'd be any U.S
president who would say yes we are going
to temporarily pause immigration we've
had immigration moratoriums there were
immigrants who would get in we would
still you know it's never a full stop
right but it's but it's very very heavy
stop
um and yeah I mean the immigrants we've
been bringing in Non-Stop for 80 years
how about we help them their pay go up
who is it hurting to say no more no more
immigrants not hurting me my pool boy
gets cheaper and cheaper and cheaper my
gardeners get cheaper my life is
fantastic but the immigrants themselves
ought to be charging a lot more to do
that drywalling they don't need to
they're a million more and they're
coming right across the border let's
read this from Joe a he says I was a
student at Berkeley when Anne spoke I
was a moderate at the time so I didn't
attend watching the students Psychotic
Reaction to her presence started my path
to the right
excellent
um one thing I'd like to say about that
there were 2 000 antifa there to stop me
why did the speech go off without two
thousand without a hitch one reason
I had the proud boys
and that's why they want to destroy the
proud boys and act like their white
supremacists when Gavin McGinnis is on
air talking to what's his name Tariq
whatever it is
um saying we're not going to January 6th
we are not going that is our official
policy they have like 30 000 members of
The Proud boys and what a dozen two
dozen of them went there
but the way they treat the proud boys as
if they're talking about the clan it's
because they don't want people like me
to be protected they don't want people
like you guys to be protected they don't
want the poor the poor students coming
to see a speech by me they don't want
their them to be protected
all right Heron gaming says you should
have a Mr bocus stream and donate to
charity to fund stem cell treatment I
love that it'd be hard to stream him he
doesn't stay in one place we just get
him to sleep stayed in one place here
yeah he likes my coach he went back you
can you can use the lint roller to get
all that oh thank you I'll take a little
buckle with you for the room
all right Eagle Eye says I disagree that
Soros saying to Santa's is ruthless
isn't a compliment for him considering
Soros himself is considered a
Machiavellian character but he was
saying he his Hope was they go to war so
the Democrats went in a landslide like
that is not endorsing a candidate
and you shouldn't pick candidates based
on who endorses them or doesn't endorse
them yeah
Ted delorio says from last night driving
stick when you stop on Hills at the
parking brake as you let off the clutch
release the parking brake and go easy
yep I mean that's still in that lesson
about more complicated than driving
automatic and just pressing the gas
San Francisco
yeah sir Elliot with the two dollar
Super Chat says two buckos
that's right all right
Ithaca crime says hi Anne sorry about
what went down when you spoke at Cornell
I have a plan to flood Ithaca with
illegals Martha's Vineyard style should
I go for it yes
is that well I mean just Rhonda Santos
get him on the phone
it's crazy how they lost their minds
over what Joe Biden was literally doing
to other cities and then they moved all
of the immigrants off Mars
but Ron he was a bad guy we love them
they enriched us now get the and
they're gonna charge it with the human
trafficking at one point they're trying
to say like yeah it's like it's like the
quintessential nimbyism like right there
it's like the definition
DeSantis is good Rundell Schmidt says
Trump had to fight for years to get the
money to build the wall that's why it
didn't get finished he needed to get his
second term to finish number one he had
a republican house and a Republican
Senate for two years and what did he
push through a tax cut without ending
the carried interest loophole which is
just a gift to hedge fund managers
number two he's president of the United
States He is commander-in-chief the
number one job he has is protecting our
borders he never needed congress's
approval
all right Mark gadetti says the border
wall is important but getting the F out
of Ukraine is way more important sandus
won't get us out of Ukraine or end the
ATF what I wish I could expand have him
explain that I don't know that that's I
don't think I looked this up and
DeSantis I mean Governors you can judge
them by what they've had to handle like
covid
um which oh yeah Trump totally bloomed
Sans did it right yeah I don't think you
said anything about Ukraine
but you're a chat person I agree with
him on that's the one thing I'm worried
about with the Sams I don't want him to
be in neocon yeah and a lot of the
donors are neocons that's what people
are worried about one of the big things
yes Kenneth Hart says Mr bocus is kitta
12 out of 10 would pet
what life
all right pet rock says DeSantis ain't
about the wall and is lying again
did you say he was about the wall no I
think that person isn't very bright you
said you said Ronald give us a wall
I hope he will oh yeah
well all right let's read some more
tophera says gotta push back on Ian
thinking the ruling Powers want
immigrants to fill Soldier scarcity San
Diego no longer requires peace officers
to be citizens or even permanent
residents to enroll citizenship is being
degraded oh but they they're allowing
non-citizens to enroll so that is kind
of agreeing with Mike yes redoubling
your point geez that's what happened
with the Romans when they started using
foreign mercenaries as their militaries
when it all right yeah that's true Rhys
Mendocino says I think you all should
watch kraut's video labeled Trump's
biggest mistake it goes over immigration
trade Wars and more I think it's a good
video for a different perspective I've
seen that
what's the perspective
um I won't be able to Bullet down right
now okay does it blame someone other
than the president of the United States
for what happened under that President
of the United I think it's literally
called Trump's biggest mistake yeah it's
yeah Trump's
all right what do we got Druid Arrow
says census should have the citizen
question by law so the three-fifth
Clause could have been applied to
non-citizens and hit all states so
Appropriations and representation was
more accurate constitutionally
I'm surprised the census does not have
the citizenship question but of course
Democrats greatly oppose it they
couldn't give us a real reason as to why
they did they want people to get yanked
out of their bedrooms at two in the
morning yeah we're totally doing I mean
you mean people who are committing
crimes shouldn't be arrested I'm not
sure I follow it's a non-violent crime I
think they're concerned about family
they're they're police officers in
California nobody's getting ripped out
of his bed at 2AM also shouldn't we know
right if we're supposed to fund everyone
who's here and offer them Social
Services wouldn't we need an accurate
count of who's here I get the fear but
like at some point the logic breaks
there's no fear
there's no fear it's top Crystal Crystal
Max says and I've been such a such a fan
of you probably 20 years I swear I
remember you uh you from the Lost times
of O'Reilly and Hannity and Hannity
Combs great to see you
yeah you you were not working I thought
you were working at the network so you
were always like uh independent and
you'd come in and do like a show did you
start it on MSNBC
oh wow but weren't they more
conservative back in the day Tucker
Carlson was on MSNBC
as we know Tucker Carlson doesn't
believe anything I don't know he was on
PBS on CNN yeah foxes in the last game I
think people used to just have more
variety and perspective well yeah it
isn't just fox or MSNBC it would there
were TV was just better back then now
it's you can do it in your sleep
you just say the same things over and
over yeah the real fire Brands start
their own thing their own network here's
a good one everybody get your drinks
ready Kyle Miller says Anne what are
your thoughts of Tim's prediction of a
second civil war Civil event happening
they said
um I don't I mean this this will sound
funny I think that's kind of a pipe
dream
um because we feel like we'd win it I
don't think that will happen for one
thing we happen to be living in a period
of time where the most Pacific creature
on earth is the white American male I
think there are two possibilities we
just lose and lose and lose and cower
and hide and the whole country becomes
California or the brighter scenario is
we separate ourselves as
um somebody was saying we've we did over
covet oh you worked him all these people
moving to Florida people moving to Texas
we do but that's the polarization that
leads to Civil War but there doesn't
have to be a war I'm mean that is the
idea of the Constitution and what you
were saying about don't make everything
National so what's so Freedom promoting
about our constitution is all the big
stuff is supposed to be local and
Statewide so you can live in the sort of
society that you find amenable don't
want gay rights parades you know I don't
know what if they take your son to
California to castrate him what do you
do
well what if they take them to Turkey
and and give them a clitor ectomy it's
it'll it would be the same thing but you
are living in the society you want yeah
somebody can kidnap them who's the they
here Jeff younger we had him on the show
his son was taken by his wife to
California where it's a sex change uh
sanctuary and she's attempting to
chemically castrate no I know it's a
horrible horrible thing and there was
that famous actress from the TV show was
it Gossip Girl Who Married
um some kind of Arab and he kidnapped
their kids and literally took them to
the Middle East yeah that happens but
that's what we're talking about as
opposed to shutdowns across the country
as opposed to for example we were
finally liberated from this one abortion
law for the whole country as opposed to
vax mandates and and
um oh how big are toilets can be you can
you will live people are moving to
Florida because of the freedom because
police come out oh and what are they
trying to do now they want a national
law to take away the qualified immunity
for from police which is so utterly
preposterous they want Hillary wants
National and all the Democrats want
National rules for what policemen can do
no no I want policemen operating in my I
will live in Florida thank you Joe Biden
and AOC
um so I think we will divide ourselves
up much more yes there can always be
kidnappings and especially with spouses
and they can take them out of the
country forget another part of the
country but except for someone
kidnapping your child probably your
ex-spouse you'll live in the world where
we're going to have school prayer in our
schools we're not going to have masks in
our schools we're not going to have
teach you know kindergartners about anal
sex in our schools and I think that's
you're you're already seeing it so I
mean look at the states that gained
population and look at the states that
lost population we are dividing
ourselves up and that's the problem
I don't think it is a problem I'm very
happy living in a red State I think
there's there's obviously not positives
you know you're living in a redstone now
you are West Virginia yeah we moved here
a while ago because of this stuff but
the G so what starts with ideological
polarization becomes Geographic
polarization Geographic polarization
exacerbates the the tribal conflict I
don't think there's any conflict there I
think separate separates by separating
right I mean I think Canada is a
ridiculous country does it affect me no
is it going to bother me well it's I'm
personally so what happens when
California brings in a million illegal
immigrants who then vote in our federal
who then who Grant electoral power to
California to subvert Texas's will so
Texas has to have a wall but but sure
that's a problem no matter what happens
I don't know how a civil war solves that
I didn't say it does anita said what
happened my view is that a state like
Texas is forced by the federal
government to adhere to rules put in
place by California Who's acting on
unconstitutionally and illegally that is
States may have to build their own walls
and that's what leads to Civil War no
States putting up checkpoints and
setting up barriers is is geographic
hyper who's going to be who's going to
fire on Mount on on Fort Sumter what so
it I think the problem Americans have
why does that start so they shoot across
Texas's wall so take a look at the
Spanish Civil War the American Civil War
was not a traditional Civil War the
American Civil War was a secession of
elements of the country attempting to
form their own country if you look at
every other civil war in history almost
all of them it's Pockets throughout the
country like guerrilla warfare well oh
that's another reason cities versus
Urban versus rural typically but then
you'll get a faction say say they call
themselves anti-fascist action and
they're the com the militant wing of the
Communist Party fighting with the
fascists and then it's a neighborhood in
this city in a neighborhood in this city
and they've been setting up uh party
houses for organizing politics they've
been increasingly marching through the
streets and getting increasingly violent
you see stuff like maybe there's a guy
who supports one candidate getting shot
twice in the chest by a guy with a with
a Soviet with us with a communist tattoo
on his neck and then you get uh elements
throughout the rest of the country like
in Texas a man's child being taken to
California for castration okay I think
that has nothing to do with civil war
that can happen you could be taken to
the Middle East and right but what about
the increase in streets tries to shoot
some people in California or rather
Florida
everybody's arms and in Atlanta in
Georgia right now but a bunch of far
left extremists have come down and are
occupying aware in Atlanta a bunch of
far left extremists around the country
are occupying a forest and are shooting
at police burning houses down flipping
cars over and the cops just shot and
killed one of these guys so they went
into the City and started firebombing
buildings and they declared a state of
emergency and charged several people
they arrested with domestic terrorism
well these problem you're raising I
think isn't is the following that there
are red Pockets within blue States and
blue Pockets within red States
engaging in Acts of Terror one one side
is gonna move out
so when antifa goes to
a city and starts burning houses down
it's what they're doing in Atlanta well
conservatives just run away right
oh yes and
um probably Liberals are going to be
moving away from places like Florida
Texas and I hope Virginia under young
but Florida shows us that's not what's
happening what's happening is the more
conservative leaning people have fled
but the liberal people stay there
entrenching in this in this chaos not in
Florida no Florida's turning red because
what we're seeing is in these other
states people will separate themselves
out and then what do you think happens
to California and New York and Chicago
when they run out of resources because
their system doesn't work do you think
they just ignore the conservative areas
with the farms and just say no we're
starving to death but you guys are all
right well I don't know I just I don't
see them coming to you think Liberals
are content with letting conservatives
live their lives and be taking our
houses I just I don't see that happening
and if it happens then I I think we lose
because our side won't fight I agree
with that but the question is are
liberals content with letting
conservatives live their lives no so why
wouldn't they then say your laws are
wrong and we will go in Joe Biden
arrested how many products rules they
did every night they were talking about
I watched MSNBC death Santa dropping
like flies and remember the Atlantic
article on uh Governor Kemp who's by and
large terrible governor of um Georgia
but he did open this he was one of the
first to open up the state and say we're
done with the shutdown rules and the
Atlantic has an article
um Georgia's experiment with human
sacrifice so look they were very very
upset that anyone was living free
throughout their coveted rules they
didn't show up with guns
in Florida
right New Yorkers didn't come down and
say how dare you allow children to go to
school without masks but why would they
do that what I'm saying is we're seeing
in blue States
Limitless abortion and in red States
abortion total restrictions or or heavy
restrictions
out abortion is I think what we're
seeing with abortion we're getting off
topic but well no it's it's I think what
we're seeing with abortion I'm just
happy we're no longer pretending it's a
constitutional right but looking at the
election
um I think DeSantis did the right thing
as it turns out I think what people are
saying on abortion is they think it's a
murder they don't like abortion they
wouldn't do it themselves they would
tell their friends and and family
members don't have an abortion but they
don't want the law to say that because
that's the way the vote's going so let's
let's let me give you a hypothetical I
suppose uh I think what Oklahoma are
they the ones that did like an outright
ban
hardcore band an abortion I mean a
couple of them uh the one in Kansas just
passed again they have a really strict
trigger law and abortion the only
exceptions are uh rape incestor or if
there's a very serious fetal abnormality
I think oh they have that nut governor
who releases murderers
snits yeah what is it he's ridiculous
your audio just cut out and came back oh
no yeah it's uh it's just the the gum so
I'm just trying to I'm sorry gum muted
that's all yeah sorry about that so my
concern is
the uh the Civil War was not uh
depending on who you ask slavery was a
principal moral issue that that led to
it the South was concerned over you know
they thought Abraham Lincoln was going
to ban slavery Abraham Lincoln was
saying he was going to limit the
expansion of slavery right only like
five percent of people in South actually
own slaves most people actually and I'm
not going to pretend to be an academic
on this one I know many people reference
other individuals but they were I think
what four or was it seven states that
did not join the Confederacy until the
north invaded until the north sent
troops down to to war did several other
states all of a sudden shift in their
and it wasn't absolute many of these
states that uh then secondarily joined
the Confederacy were like 60 40. like
some of the people in the state a good
portion were like no we can't do this
West Virginia splitting two
so what I'm saying is
hyper partisanship hypertribalism antifa
literally killed a guy and the media
Praises them and says leave them alone
yeah they they literally shot an
innocent man twice in the chest in
Portland murder yeah the guy had a black
lives matter tattoo on his on his neck
and the media still to this day will
defend antifa yeah they burned down a
police station and the media said
peaceful protest yes and they tried to
put Kyle Rittenhouse in prison for the
rest of his life because he was simply
trying to protect his neighborhood and
and the day prior someone bashed an old
man over the back of that with a rock so
self-defense seemed warranted in this
regard now you've got stories of people
like Jeff younger and he's not the only
one people whose children are being
kidnapped so the question I have is by a
spouse
absolutely and a law in California that
says we will castrate your child yeah so
I look at the stories of say
um Bleeding Kansas and John Brown
before the Civil War started Kansas was
in its own pre-civil War as a state that
was going to be entering the Union it
was divided between whether it would be
a free or slave state and people were
shooting and killing each other John
Brown walk up to a slave owner and
blasted him in the face no questions
just done
then he tries taking over the Harpers
area you know later on he goes to
Harper's Ferry tries taking over the
Armory slaves don't Revolt he lets a
train leave Ward gets to Baltimore
federal troops come in dude gets uh
captured and eventually hanged
I look at things like that
and my concern is
the tribal polarization which has led to
death murder and violence 30 plus deaths
in the summer of 11 2020 they breached
the barricade to the White House
firebomb St John's Church they've torn
down statues all across this country
with impunity the only thing I see that
makes a civil war not happen is that
conservatives tend to be cowardly and
just flee
so when antifa shows up to their city
and fire bombs they flee to Florida
where it's safe because they have a
better leader I'm not saying all
concertos are cowardly I'm saying they
tend not to leave but when you say when
when you say cowardly I wouldn't say
cowardly what do you want them to do to
him like when antifa shows up and throws
rope over statues to tear it down
like you want them to shoot them link
arms and and uh how about this we'll
start with this
at your work when your boss comes and
says we're doing Dei training you just
say no
I mean I think people do that with with
the statues I think there are people
that would those people are cowards I
mean the thing about the statues is like
if you were like yeah I tried to stop a
mob of people from pulling over statue
during a black life matters rally like
if you become people that you are more
likely to suffer right your company is
like to be like why did you take that
position so right now what I hear is a
guy who works at Taco Bell with a black
lives matter mask on is told by his boss
you have to take it off or else and he
says then fire me I refuse to take off
my mask they fire him he films himself
on video saying they fired me for this
black lives matter protesters and antifa
inundate this guy with so much psychotic
harassment that he begs the guy to come
back and take his job back
that was like two years ago that was
like two years ago right you guys are
crap about it
things are happening to see a Civil War
coming from that yeah the Liberals are
very very very bad people the media is
very very very bad the mutilation of
children is very very bad but I mean
even with the father you keep talking
about I mean so here's what I do shoot
his wife shoot them how does the war
start uh how about speak up at your job
how about uh speak up at your place of
work how about take your kids out of
these schools but look the people who
are doing those things aren't the aren't
cowards I'm not referring to people who
are actually fighting trying to do
something and speaking out to the best
of their abilities I'm talking about the
people who will message me with
influence and say I will not speak out
because I'll lose my job well that's
everybody at Fox and all talks radio so
what happens is as Democrats continue
ballot harvesting to the maximum degree
Trump supporters continually say the
elections are being stolen from us
Carrie Lake right now the end result is
not going to be Trump supporters being
like or I shouldn't even say Trump
supporters but how many however many
million tens of millions people voted
for Trump it's not going to be every
person who voted for Trump who's who's
fervent but you might be looking at
millions and they're not just going to
in the next four years be like well you
know they put up a good fight and they
won through ballot harvesting and other
other procedural changes guess I'll just
let them keep firebombing my city
castrating kids and no sooner or later
you're going to see more stuff like we
saw with the Bundy Ranch where people
will show up and say nope to the federal
government I was on the side of the
federal government and that
as much as it looks like the Canadian
trucker thing it was federal land
what was the situation we had Eamonn
Bundy on the show I thought that they
were just defending their own land it
was the simple version is it's it's a
family that's been grazing for
Generations the federal government
claimed the land because that's what
happens over time and they said sure but
we have an easement to graze here and
they said too bad so they won in court
they were they were legally in the right
to graze on the land and the FEDS tried
stopping them and so they resisted filed
a lawsuit then the the feds uh illegally
arrested the family put them through
hoax bullsh oh it trials
and they ended up winning on across the
board the federal government overstepped
lied cheated and tried stealing you know
in regards to Civil War did not know
they won in court they won everything
they won everything the federal
government lied every step of the way to
steal land and then when they were
winning made up charges to
arrest them and we had Ammon on the show
who broke down exactly what went down
how they locked him up for years on
charges transferred him from
prison prison to try and shut them up
and stop him and he was in the legal
right the whole time and they even
murdered a guy there's a video of a guy
and they lied about it too holy was
that up anyway it was like let me
talk about the Civil Warcraft we're way
over and we gotta rap if we bury our
head in the sand it's going to go the
direction that it looks like it's gonna
go if we change the direction then we
can take it where we need to take it
that's my belief but we'll wrap it up
there and it's been a blast thanks for
hanging it has been a blast thank you
well yeah come back anytime and uh for
everybody else thanks for being members
thanks for supporting our work we do
have we just filmed the pre-show so it's
it's more conversation talk of God and
other issues while we're like setting
cameras and stuff so go become a member
at timcast.com if you want to support
our work and you want to watch that you
can follow the show at timcastirl you
can follow me personally at timcast and
you want to shout anything out yes and
follow me on subsack on
coulter.subsack.com
and it's been so fun to see you it's
been a couple years for me nice to see
you fellow DG I know it
um I'm here clear Brillo I'm a writer
for timcast.com you should follow at
timcast news on Instagram and Twitter
and if you want to follow me personally
you can follow me on Twitter at HC
brimelow and you can follow me on
Instagram at hannahclar.b have a good
weekend nice thank you for praying for
Paco it helps it works it's real um I'm
Ian cross from fallmeadingcrosslin.net
check out cast Castle youtube.com cast
Castle we had a wonderful parody of
Stephen Crowder and daily wire Jeremy
boring Ben Shapiro you're all involved
whether you want to be or not and and
for your next book uh I have a question
for you have you ever taken psychedelics
no I never will perhaps you're I want
Narcan to be replaced with bear spray
perhaps you have no idea how much I hate
drugs the Deep journey to God may be a
fascinating topic to explore in the
future I've found I've gone on that
journey and I found them you can also
get that through holotropic breathing
apparently you can can do psychedelic
experiences just through that one I
don't put the mask on I guess hey crazy
man that was awesome bye guys
uh yeah that was quite the episode
um good fun yeah it was fun I am at
surge.com Hannah Claire that was great
you did a really wonderful job you
actually uh got your your uh ATS right
this time so I'm practicing I'm getting
better at these outros yeah you're doing
well
um yeah thanks guys uh at surge.com
spell it out I'm surprised how many
people still don't understand
s-e-r-g-e-d-o-t-c-o-m answers.com on
Twitter at me let's argue let's fight
and for everybody who wants to be a
member the uh the pre-recorded
uncensored show it's up right now so
check it out timcast.com thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time